boy the wind sure whipping up out there
hey heather i've got a great deal on
wind if you want some of that and we've
got plenty of it that's right not hard
to find all you got to do is step
outdoors today look at the clouds so
this is all around a cold front that's
been really delivering some strong winds
i've got the top wind speeds especially
up in the mountains air quality advisory
for dust we've seen elevated dust levels
already through the morning hours with
these strong winds so moderate air
quality overall top wind gusts angel
peak 8 800 feet up in the spring
mountains had an 84 mile per hour that's
hurricane force winds earlier this
morning kyle canyon near 50 mile per
hour winds same for mountain springs
summit between prump and las vegas
boulder city over 45 miles per hour
winds same for red rock a lot of areas
now are seeing 40 to 45 mile-per-hour
wind gusts still under wind advisories
for the valley and lower elevations of
clark county temperatures have not moved
a lot since early this morning in fact
some neighborhoods are going down
cooling off as that cooler air
approaches us with that cold front and
i'll show you where it is coming up 57
now in summerlin where we've had some
cool little brief showers and sprinkles
and those showers are moving quickly
through southern clark county 45 in
caliani 53 at indian springs strong
winds there perhaps not as windy as the
rest of the area 52 right now mid 60's
in boulder city a long a lot of wind in
kingman at 68 46 up in reno where they
had a little rain and snow earlier this
morning here's the cold front it's
getting closer to us and here's the rain
and the snow around it and again these
are very brief but we are getting bona
fide sprinkles nothing measurable so far
although i do think down around sandy
valley we could see some measurable
rainfall right now the showers seem a
little bit heavier and i've checked lee
canyon's webcam they're getting a little
bit of light snow up there at the ski
resort wind advisories will stay in
effect until five o'clock this afternoon
the wind advisory for the mountains was
allowed to expire
earlier today around 11 a.m about an
hour or more ago 69 we'll have sunshine
clouds sprinkles a lot of this whipping
wind for the next several hours and then
again by the evening commute i think the
winds will really start to calm down but
we're going to be cool temperatures not
even up to 70 degrees today we'll start
off tomorrow in the 40s with those
lighter winds and a few cool mornings
with temperatures really below normal
for a few days we'll get back to some
upper 70's even low 80s by friday and a
nice weekend with occasional clouds
moving through our skies heather boy
what a difference a day makes
all right